what do you do for a living trying to
truck some nobleman job yes
you all in from the beginning get out
like this is for non-indian people when
you're always like oh why not just you
minorities in general you know however
like whatever crime
it turns out that there are like
differences I realized and I realized
because it turnings lights over with the
different kinds of Indians like this
table is pin jumping right punjabi
people are our irish
bunch of meals getting drunks who love
to fight
take him anywhere without worrying
they're gonna call the [ __ ] scene you
know not even real life job few people
had the style of dance no one could ever
see map with this right here in all this
is is you just flip a Riverdance upside
down
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
dropping people anything you gotta keep
on like the details here is the
environment Patel that's bedrock
they are our Jews
they are real estate
got a ton of money they all pretended
along
technology really real sorry I got
nothing
why me
[Music]
also much like the Jews none of us like
a man we don't have a real reason
[Music]
any mother people here two of them so
what's your last name's Georgia
something like that
humming joking George if you ever see
like a dark skin do with like a white
last name he's mowing off you're calling
numbers they are our black people I
don't mean to be so crude but basic
darkness that's offspring also they go
to the same barbers all of them and
they're all Christian and we pretend it
was a choice
[Music]
I'm waiting for lots of room
like all section in the bank is didn't
get
[Music]